a covid vaccine is seen as the great
hope
protecting health securing the economy a
ticket
back to normality but the uk
is only buying doses for those who are
most vulnerable
that's 30 million people less than half
the population
jack summers volunteered for one of the
vaccine trials
despite the emerging risk of long covid
it's by no means certain the young and
healthy would actually be protected
i think it would be quite a shock and i
think that probably results from
uh the fact that the government has told
us so often that this is a sort of has
told us about it very simple terms that
it's a there will be a vaccine
one day and that will solve all our
problems in in one fell swoop
the vaccines task force has only brought
doses on the assumption they'll be given
to people over 50
those with underlying health problems
and to health and care workers
but with so few vaccinated there's
little prospect of herd immunity
the virus will still spread this advisor
to the world health organization
says the first vaccines may only take
the edge off symptoms
so the young and healthy may not benefit
if all you know about a vaccine is that
it's capable of preventing
people from getting sick then
the only really logical thing you can do
with it on that evidence
is to try and stop people getting sick
and the people who get
sick are pretty much the elderly some
countries
are rolling out the vaccine to everyone
herd immunity is the explicit goal of
australia to stop the virus spreading
japan is hoping to secure enough doses
to protect its population
by next summer and germany has also said
it's aiming for herd immunity but the uk
is not alone in targeting the vaccine at
those most at risk
canada is drawing up a priority list for
the first available doses of vaccine
and belgium is doing the same ethics
experts say governments need to be
transparent about who gets the vaccine
it's unlikely that a vaccine a safe
vaccine will be available
in enough quantity for it to be
distributed
to the majority of the population in
order to achieve herd immunity
instantly or at least very quickly and
so
we have to make some difficult ethical
decisions around
allocation at that point the first one
would be on your right
right kate bingham the uk's vaccines
chief and a volunteer in one of the
clinical trials
told sky news earlier this month that
the first vaccines are likely to be only
partially effective
they won't end the pandemic but with
luck they'll stop so many people
dying thomas more sky news